I suppose really what I must want to ask
you is how you can possibly justify
investigating anything so totally
useless the string theory hi Robert so
you asked why how can you justify
studying anything as obviously useless
as string theory well that's a loaded
question let's assume that string theory
is on the right direction to
understanding the fundamental laws of
nature at this incredibly small scale
where quantum gravity becomes relevant
and the forces of nature unify of what
use could that possibly be and I must
admit I can think of no use at all
except in satisfying my and I'm sure
your curiosity as to how the universe
works
what are the forces of nature how are
they unified how does space-time behave
at short distances out of black holes
behave and maybe even what happens at
the cosmological Big Bang the origin of
the universe satisfied once curiosity is
a goal in of itself and much of science
is based on just trying to understand
the answer to these wonderful questions
that we have always asked and now ask
with more precision is it of use that's
good enough for me
but it might be even of you more use why
you ask this question of string
theorists I don't know
you might ask it of astronomers of what
usage is to look and to try to
understand what the universe is made out
of how its structured and how it evolved
that is of no use at all but on the
other hand it is of great use in making
us feel
like the intelligent creatures we are
that would like to understand more and
more about the world in which we live
and as scientists as physicists we must
always remember that elements research
in physics the very fundamental level
have often led in the past to actual
technology things which are directly of
used to human beings in ways that none
of the scientists at the time could have
could have imagined this has been the
case since electricity and magnetism
were explored for reasons of curiosity
and certainly was that is the case with
respect to the quantum world which was
discovered a effort to understand the
microscopic world without any idea of
how those theories and would be applied
to all the devices of modern technology
I cannot imagine into my largest
attempts of imagining new technological
developments that the problems that
string theory attempts to solve even if
we had a solution to those problems it
could lead to technological inventions
but who knows